the nfc east meets the eye with the
worst division in football from last
year we've been doing draft needs today
is nfc east and nfc east only will do
afc east tomorrow the nfc east teams and
let's begin with the dallas cowboys even
though they didn't win it everybody
thinks they're going to the cowboys with
the 10th pick in the draft they can't
leave the draft weekend without what
chris well i mean this one's easy as far
as dallas is concerned i mean it we know
it's defensive side of the ball right
we've talked about that a little bit
over the last few weeks it could really
be anywhere
you know on the defense for the most
part but i think you know the one that
jumps out something on the defensive
line a difference maker on the defensive
line they got to come out of the draft
and have you know
one player multiple players that they
feel like are going to be able to
contribute to their football team going
into the 2021 season we know it was
underwhelming last year there's no doubt
you know uh
uh pass rusher there's nothing that's
coming off the edge there in that
department so you know from that
standpoint that's where i look at them
defensive tackle who is there that
really jumps out to you about their
football team you know i mean demarcus
lawrence is really the only standout guy
they have on their front four
and he's not that stand out to where you
just go oh man he's such a game changer
and he makes everybody better and
everything like that no so i i just look
at them that's where i look at number 10
they could have the pick of the litter
as far as the pass rushers in the draft
but they got to come away with some sort
of difference maker on the d-line this
year
i did a thing yesterday kind of breaking
down where the top 10 picks are going
team by team guy by guy and there's a
chance that the first nine players taken
this year will be all offensive players
right and and so the cowboys whose needs
are clustered on the descent defensive
side of the ball it's kind of like
having the first pick in the draft
you've got the run
of any defensive player you want that's
why this kyle pitts talk is so
confounding to me and i think one of the
reasons it's been leaked is because
there are people in the organization
that are trying to keep jerry jones from
either using the 10th pick on kyle pitts
or trading up and giving up other assets
to get pits when their needs are so much
more obvious chris on the defensive side
of the ball so i i agree with you
especially as they you know they went
from
a defense that wasn't suited to mike
nolan they made changes last year to
make it suited to mike nolan and now
it's dan quinn and you have other needs
and you've got to have that pass rush
you've got to find difference makers and
they just don't have them on that side
of the ball no period they really don't
uh they're actually in a great spot with
all that run-on quarterbacks they don't
need a quarterback
run on receivers they definitely don't
need receivers with the guys they have
they're they're going to be sitting
pretty at 10 if they have the discipline
to avoid the temptation to take kyle
pitts if he's even still yeah you know
and mike i mean just you know off of
that too i mean in that scenario and
there is some scenarios where you could
play out the the whole mock draft thing
and go
wait you know if this works out i mean
kyle pitts could be there at number 10
for the cowboys maybe they say that
knowing how high he is up on everybody
else's draft board hoping that maybe
somebody will swoop in and maybe want to
trade to pick 10 and they can drop down
a few spots maybe and still get a player
or the players they want you know that's
another possibility that's certainly
floated through my brain but yes i mean
they're in prime territory for a guy you
know for for the two best pass rushers
in the draft for my opinion jalen
phillips we've talked about from miami i
mean to me he's got superstar potential
but there's that concussion issue if
it's not him i would think it's quiddy
pay from michigan and they're they're
difference makers
and again you know getting back to our
old seattle scheme conversation i mean
we know all teams like pass rushers but
this is a scheme that there is more
emphasis on the wide nine and come off
the edge and we don't worry about you
know the run game quite as much and we
want to get just four after the
quarterback and play seven in zone and
do all that you know to me it's
imperative to make this system work and
i got to think the cowboys are thinking
that to help out dan quinn
they don't have a veteran presence at
backup quarterback and and we learned
last week there can be a disconnect
between the official online roster and
who really is under contract but the
roster right now shows ben dinucci
garrett gilbert and cooper rush
behind dak prescott yeah
do they need a developmental guy with
one of these draft picks i think they're
better off trying to sign a veteran i
just don't know really who's out there
that could come in and and provide the
kind of support that prescott needs year
six in his career yeah to me you're
you're you're playing with fire there a
little bit i i i do think so you got
this high octane offense don't you want
a quarterback who can you know if dak
prescott let's just say
hurts the ankle just a little bit tweaks
the ankle that he's coming back from
surgery with and all that has to miss a
few weeks don't you want a quarterback
that could take advantage of all that
that talent on your offensive side of
the ball can deliver you know i mean we
saw last year andy dalton was good he
couldn't even deliver to the point dak
prescott could uh but i would think that
that would be something maybe that they
draft kind of just get a feel for hey
training camp maybe they think about it
then they might just go into training
camp in pre-season to go let's see maybe
these guys can do it and if not you get
to the end of training camp and then
they sign one of the veterans that gets
cut or something like that
you know i'm looking at the list of
available veterans and gee boy uh not a
lot of options
alex smith i think alex smith wants a
play
but uh he may be a guy that that you
think about from the standpoint of
having a veteran presence in the event
that dak prescott would have an issue
with the ankle new york giants 11th
overall pick right behind the dallas
cowboys
six picks in all tied for third fewest
in the draft what do they
have to get you're giants chris
giants what do they need well i i mean
you know first off like the doubt i mean
the giants are an interesting
conversation i mean i think the roster
and team is a little bit better maybe
than
you know we think before you start to
dive in a little bit you know i hear
people say they i think they might need
a receiver and all that no way they
don't need a receiver i mean they got
gallaudet darius slayton's really good
sterling shepherd's still real good i
mean he's a good slot receiver you know
and they have evan ingram a titan
they're good in the pass game you know
to me
you know
could they o line help certainly still a
conversation i think you know nate
solder is getting up there in years the
offensive line wasn't great last year
they don't have zeitler anymore at guard
i think though when i really comes down
to it
i come back to some sort of edge
presence not that they have to take him
and pick you know i think it's 11 right
in the draft not that they need a pass
rusher but i do think there needs to be
something on the edge there you know
when it's third down to get hey we got a
real true legit edge pass rusher to
affect the quarterback on third and four
plus you know that that leonard williams
is their best pass rusher and he's not
really a pass rusher he's really a
defensive tackle who's got some
versatility to come out on the edge and
be a handful that way so there's a few
issues i look at but i think that's the
one i look at more than other that i
would think somewhere in that first
three rounds they try to make us point
to get some real speed off the edge to
be that guy
they're two super bowl teams of this
century had great offensive line great
defensive line you got to be able to
create havoc we were reminded yet again
in super bowl 55 that's right it means
to have a great pass rush what it did to
patrick mahomes and they've loaded up so
much on the offensive side of the ball
it makes sense and they're in great
position too especially if kyle pitts is
still there at 10 and it's 10 for 10
offensive players they've got the first
pick in the draft as it relates to where
their needs are clustered on the
defensive side of the ball it's great
it's gonna go very well for the cowboys
and the giants yeah top ten no
definitely i'm excited as a giant fan
because you know really
you know you could say the edge guy like
we talked about you know they could use
another corner hey james bradbury was
really good last year but everything
else as far as cover corners
it's kind of unproven you know yeah they
they signed um you know what's his name
from from the tennis dory jackson thank
you
you know they gave him some money but
again you could be thinking the future
there's there's that issue there and
then oh lineman like we talked about
to your point mike pick of the litter
really you know as far as at that point
of the draft number 11. so they should
be able to get the best player available
for the need they feel like they need to
dress the most and that to me as a
giants fan is is very exciting but yeah
i i would expect it to be an edge type
guy too you know there early in the
draft something something along those
lines
and we continue the run through the nfc
east 10 11
12 cowboys giants eagles man with that
12th overall pick what must they get i
think it's it's probably a team
no i i mean you're right there's really
not one part of the team other than i
think offensive line that you could
probably look at offensive lines the
only spot i look at and go they're good
there's not like a necessity i mean you
got lane johnson they got you know
dillard at left tackle who got hurt last
year brandon book brooks is coming back
you know what guard he's real good but i
i think the the thing i come back to
more than anything i think mike and i
don't know here because you said it
there's a lot of spots i do think it's
wide receiver you know again not saying
they got to come away with one at number
12 but i would think like you know a
jalen waddle or somebody like that would
certainly pique their interest there you
know but again there's gonna be a good
one there in round two at pick 37 as far
as a a wide receiver they can get but
they gotta come away with something else
at that position that to me i mean jalen
rieger was disappointing
there's no doubt you and there's not a
lot else on that roster that's real
special so to me that would probably be
the one spot i look at that like man
they need something there badly
and they ended up at 12 by choice they
were at six they traded down they
stockpiled a first round pick next year
making that move down six spots and and
yeah again if they're looking defense
yeah they could be doing they should be
looking everywhere they're in another
great spot where
run on offensive players one through
nine maybe one through ten and you're in
a great spot to get a player where they
definitely need help and they agree
foster just has fallen apart in three
years they got a lot of work
to do you you are you with that there or
you think they should go like defensive
line or or corner
best corner i mean because you're i mean
your point's real you're no doubt about
it they can really again like the giants
in a way could probably sit there and go
wait best player available at the
position we feel like we need the most
uh it's a tough call with the eagles
you know what i would do if i were the
eagles i would hope and pray that one of
the top five quarterbacks is still on
the board and i would auction that pick
and keep trading down because they are
in a spot where they need to maximize
their lottery tickets right they need as
many guys that possibly could be
scratched off and turn into good players
as they can get because one draft is not
going to fix it but if you can get extra
picks next year extra picks this year go
from 12 down to
15 you know if the patriots want to
spring up and get justin fields if he
somehow slips through the cracks and is
there at 12 fine what do you want to
move up three spots we'll move down
we'll move down we'll move down more
picks more picks more picks i think
that's the key more picks greater shots
at finding guys who will come in and
make a difference sooner rather than
later so i i i think i'm the eagles i'm
talking to everybody drafting behind me
about the possibility of trading down
even far no i think that makes sense i
mean it does it's a good thought i think
it's exactly why
you know they traded out of that number
six spot they probably had the same
logic you did they just went wait
one great pick is not gonna fix our team
we need to get get players all over our
roster we gotta get younger deeper
everything so i think that that's why
they made that move and i wouldn't be
shocked you know again you know maybe
they're they're sitting in a pretty good
spot you're right to where there might
be some action there if the draft falls
the right way for them
then come the defending nfc east
champions the washington football team
picking 19th not as obviously in need of
a quarterback because of the presence of
ryan fitzmagic as long as he stays away
from fitz tragic they have an extra
third round pick from the trent williams
trade from last year they've done a lot
in free agency to quietly make the team
better adding receiver curtis samuel
adding a cornerback guy you love in
william jackson the third they throw in
adam humphries to the mix this is a team
that has not gotten worse and has gotten
better so far in the offseason what do
they need chris in the draft more than
anything else well i mean quarterback is
certainly like a big red flag when you
talk about washington i gotta think
there's some thought about finding
somebody for the future here with the
football team to a degree
you know and again i i
if those one of those quarterbacks do
fall kind of like you talked about
you know trey lance justin fields if
they were on the board there you know at
11 12 i don't know would washington be
one of those teams that would maybe make
a move i think they're definitely going
to take one if one falls to them at some
point at number 20.
you know are they a team that's in the
second round tries to trade up to the
early second late first something like
that to get a quarterback you know i i
don't know that's certainly like the big
thing but i don't think they're going to
be like desperate just to make it happen
like kind of like you talked about they
got some guys there i think they think
they can win with fitzpatrick with the
way their team's orchestrated so yeah
quarterback's a big need but like if we
weren't gonna talk quarterback the next
one to me is tackle that that's for sure
like they need to find a tackle and i
would think that at pick 20 you know if
the quarterback conversation's over
right and all the quarterbacks have gone
or whatever else that tackle would be
their focus there with that pick i mean
again the roster pretty well built there
in washington they're close
and they got a good guard and sheriff
but i think tackle's the one position
that jumps out to me that washington
needs to address at least in the first
few rounds of the draft for sure yeah
and hey look with sherf who's in the
second year of the franchise tag they're
not going to use a third tag on him
because it becomes quarterback money
right that's another guy that is going
to need to potentially be replaced so at
a time when they have a great defensive
line they need to be putting some assets
into the offensive line maybe before
they have their next franchise
quarterback not after they get him maybe
this is about laying the foundation for
improving the offensive line and then
next year is the year yeah depending
upon who's left
who's going to be there at 19. will
there be a guy there at 19. will someone
trade up in front of washington because
even though washington and chicago
signed veteran quarterbacks i think we
kind of look at them and say yeah they
could they could be spots where that
that leftover quarterback gets drafted i
just think they need to be thinking
about a future when they get their
franchise guy
have the infrastructure in place to
protect him i think that's the key for
washington this year yeah i'm with you
mike you know and again it's a team that
i certainly got in my eye on because i i
think they're
they could be really dangerous curtis
samuel in free agency william jackson at
corner you know that's secondary now
pretty good you talked about that d line
oh we added that receiver to the group
and samuel with terry mclaurin that's
pretty good you know logan thomas a
tight end it's a legit pass catching
threat the running backs are okay like
washington's on the up and up and this
is the kind of draft too mike to like
what you're saying where they could come
away with you can come away with two
starting offense alignment it's it's a
pretty it's a pretty good talented class
of offense alignment to where you know
if you're smart you might be able to
really bolster that part of your
football team
the cowboys previously were the
overwhelming favorites from a betting
standpoint to win the division i guess
just because they're the cowboys i mean
i think washington
is the team to watch and and it's
improving from february 9 when it was
overwhelmingly dallas at 125 and
everyone else well there's philly at
plus 210 i that can't be right that's
got that can't it can't have been plus
210 it was plus 210 wow well now it's
plus 550 for them and washington is down
from plus 800 and i misread the graphic
because my eyes are old new york was
plus 600 so washington went from being
the long shot despite being the
defending champion to now second at plus
270. still a good bet i think they're
the best team clearly in that division
right now chris when you consider
everything what they did last year what
they've added the presence of ron rivera
the addition of martin mayhew and marty
herney to the front office this move
away from dysfunction
i i i'm my god
if you're a washington fan good right
good keep keep assuming that we're not
going to be the champions of the
division again and then we'll just go
about week in and week out showing that
we're the best team in the division i
think they are as of right now i'm i'm
with you i i'm there with you too i mean
if you made me pick right now middle of
april who's going to win the nfc east
i'm going with washington
i just have less questions about you
know their football team
and really honestly after that
there's no way i'm not going dallas
number two either
no way
you know not with like dak prescott not
definitely gonna be a hundred hundred
percent to start the year and any of
that and that defense like i gotta see
it to believe it i mean yeah again i
know we changed the defensive
coordinator they got
they're not a highly talented defense in
dallas i i would go the giants is the
number two team the giants to the next
team i look at to go man there's some
things to like there it's a borderline
top 10 defense last year you know i mean
would they improve their wide receivers
the tight end saquon barkley's going to
be back i to me i would say washington
and the giants are clearly the two
better teams in the league are in that
division over the cowboys right now
the fact that the cowboys are still the
favorite just shows the value
and hype and hype and every year it's
hype and hype and hype and the cowboys
are the one team that give zero craps
about the
bar being too high because every year
the bar is high because they talk it
high
and it stays high and then they they
fail to come even close to satisfying
what it is that they need to do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports